my name is Jake and here are some of the
weirdest and funniest intros we've seen
so far from the orcs in shadow of war
make sure to check back later this week
for the review and beware there might be
spoilers enjoy I was bitten by the
spiders of mortal and I didn't I teach I
have embraced their venom I have
embraced their call I am one with the
spiders my black speech is a little
rusty exelon our single wood which is a
pint in the ass but that has it a case
he sayd Rubin a die horribly mark on a
black I will handle the Overlord you
focus on the defenders define focus yeah
well suffer trespasser you will feel the
knowing Ross why wouldn't God Dorian
come here and try to murder all of the
orcs maybe you have a problem with one
orc
maybe a hundred but oh all of us maybe
the problem is with you
yeah that works I'm a thinker I think
code you know I think hard harder than
all the rest then it's what makes me the
most Pastis remember me now and hear me
later
I am the AB statistics you don't
recognize me because now I have a clue
where my heart used to be you took one
of my beats now I'm gonna take one of
yours
we might benefit a crook and this piece
up pretty in my hand I'm proud to call
you to call you brothers proud proud Oh
Schrock look at his eyes and you'll see
the true terror of Mordor after that you
won't see much only the choicest
materials I scoured them to strip away
fight soften them by pounding it down
and soaking them in categories and when
I slip into your charred hide I make you
a little cold
where are we we're gonna fake your
threat I think he wore tasty morsel too
small of a full meal part interesting
little tip delicacy seems to me I
already killed you and I saw that recall
properly but that's the same not the
kind of thing you'd miss remember where
you left your knife for what you had for
breakfast you could get confused on that
but killing a man
come here Mina boys wash areas of orcish
gardeners
hi there why it's a lonely lonely man
why though we keep him company the
Uruguay you die now boss
[Music]
[Applause]
you run from me before how could you
leave me Lord that or plan to be so
close to you oh no what it is to return
from death or light in its cold grasp on
the battlefield until a squirming
wriggling war to go to me a thousand
thousand pulsing maggots rolled over and
into me scouring the dead flesh for more
ragged wounds now they are with me
always a churning writhing hoard of da
man
fresh maggot food
[Music]